the libs indicted Trump again
four more times to be precise all over
January 6th the worst day in the history
of this or any Republic
now given the number of times that
they've done this already and are sure
to do it again in the future this would
not even be a headline news story save
for the unfortunate fact that this case
is being tried in Washington D.C a town
far less favorable to Trump than Florida
where the last charges are scheduled to
be tried the other thing that makes this
trial a little bit more newsworthy than
the usual Democrat attacks against Trump
is that one of the punishments for the
charges in this case is death one of the
potential punishments here
is death
they want to kill him
it's not just they want to undermine his
campaign in 2016 and spy on him and tap
Trump Tower it's not just they want to
impeach him over some nonsense it's not
even just they want to get him to drop
out of the presidential race or they
want to even put him behind bars they
want to kill him they want him dead they
would dance in the streets if this man
died and they would gleefully kill him
this according to 18 U.S codes section
one of the charges here is conspiracy
against rights and includes a penalty of
up to 10 years in federal prison but it
says this if death results from The Acts
committed in violation of this section
or if such acts include kidnapping or an
attempt to kidnap aggravated sexual
abuse or an attempt to commit aggravated
sexual abuse or any attempt to kill they
shall be fined under this title or
imprisoned for any term of years or for
life or both
or maybe sentenced to death
so
you might say well look it's just one
potential
punishment involved in just one of the
charges here and it's only if anyone
dies if death results from these acts
committed but the Liberals have been
arguing since day one that Trump is
responsible for death on January 6th and
the way that they made that argument is
first they just lied and they said that
police officers died because the
pro-trump mob killed them on January 6th
that is a complete lie it never happened
uh the the newspapers had to correct the
story there is one death that did occur
though
ironically the only death from political
violence on January 6 was the death of a
trump supporter killed by a
trigger-happy cop at the Capitol
nevertheless you read 18 USC section 241
you say well all right death did result
from The Acts allegedly committed by
Trump here again the notion that he he
committed these acts is absolutely
laughable
but they've made it this far guys
they impeached him twice but they
impeached him over this they are
bringing so far what
three separate indictments three
separate batches of indictments against
him they're gonna have a lot more to
come
and they want to kill him they want to
kill him they mean business this is
forget about Trump for a second this is
the payoff of the media constantly lying
sometimes people ask why why are the
media constantly telling these small
lies about people
they did it to me earlier this year
remember I went to CPAC I said that for
the good of society especially for the
good of the poor people who fall and
pray to this confusion
the whole ideology at every level
could not have been clearer what I was
talking about they accused me of
genocide they libled me they actually
had to change the headlines I think
because their lawyers called them but
why tell a lie like that what's the
what's the end goal of that
the purpose of telling these small lies
Trump incited people to violence Trump
killed people for whatever whatever
nonsense it's so obvious is so that
they get the payoff
later on later on when they're building
this whole case and it's just faded into
memory what happened on January 6th oh I
heard I heard there was a lot of
violence I heard the pro-trump people
killed people okay that's fine it
justifies it this is why president Trump
is using this campaign line uh which is
I think one of his most effective ones
he says look they're not come after me
they're coming after you they're not
indicting me they're indicting you you
know they're not indicting me they're
indicting you I just happen to be
standing in their way that's all it is
but what you
want you thank you
what you're witnessing is a continuation
of the single greatest Witch Hunt of all
time
this is prosecutorial misconduct and his
primary purpose is to steal another
election
they're all
in a very coordinated attack trying to
take away our election of 2024 they
rigged the presidential election of 2020
we're not going to allow them to rig the
presidential election of 2024.
this is a great line he's tested this
out before and it's true even if you
hate the guy I think you have to
recognize the line is true why are they
going after Trump is it because he kept
classified documents
no we know it's not that because lots of
other politicians in both parties and
especially the Democrats have done that
the OJ doesn't go after them is it
because he incited people to Riot
even let's say you think he did that
it's obviously not for that the
Democrats have openly called for
violence against Republicans for years
now Maxine Waters go to their homes
where their children sleep push back on
them Hillary Clinton don't be civil with
Republicans Eric Holder the list goes on
and on and on and then the Democrats
actually did it for eight months
straight they burned the sit the country
down see to shining sea so it's not that
what is it is it because he where are
the other stupid charges against him
oh they said that he he manhandled a
woman in a Bergdorf Goodmans which was
completely Preposterous uh really you
want to bring that up we're talking
about the Democratic party of of uh Bill
Clinton and Bob Menendez and actually
Joe Biden if we're talking about these
kinds of allegations no I don't think so
what is it is it because he made uh an
in-kind contribution to his own campaign
allegedly through this porn star payoff
whatever are you kidding me you want to
talk about dodgy campaign contributions
the Democrat the Democrats are going to
accuse us of that pot calling the kettle
black no it's just not it's none of
those things it's because Donald Trump
represents a populist conservative
traditional nationalist strain on the
American right it's a strain that the
libs thought they had neutered for about
50 years and they hadn't it came back
again and they're going to throw
everything at him they're not indicting
him they're indicting you you might even
think that he's a deeply imperfect
representative of you you might not even
like the guy he represents you in the
mind of the Liberals okay we've got
an attorney for the president on the
line to help explain this indictment
very very quickly right now go to
goodranchors.com use promo code Knowles
you know I love anything made with top
of the line quality for meat that's good
ranchers the only thing missing from
good ranchers I was saying the sweet
little Elise about a month ago was a
pork box was
because if you ask they deliver good
ranchers has just launched their Prime
pork 100 American pork that is
Steakhouse quality this new pork box
comes with bone-in and boneless pork
chops sausage smoked brats and more plus
right now you will get 30 bucks off with
my code Knowles Canada wles at
goodranchers.com on their site you can
explore their All-American cuts of prime
pork prime beef better than organic
chicken options I eat good ranchers
constantly I just love it it the quality
is out of this world I especially love
the rib eyes I was never a huge rib eye
guy the rib eye one of the best I've
ever had they're Burgers I've had a
billion burgers in my life probably the
best hamburgers I've ever had in my
entire life
the quality is just out of this world
the prices cannot be beat and right now
if you go to goodranchers.com use code
and also you will get 30 bucks off any
box promo code knows kwles
goodranchors.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure you
are getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day through
balance of Nature's Advanced cold vacuum
process the vitamins minerals and
phytonutrients that the fruits and
veggies are preserved so that you can
get that vital nutrition in each capsule
balance of nature is a whole food
supplement with no additives fillers
extracts synthetics pesticides or added
sugar pure fruits and veggies are the
only things they put in their capsules
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for our team
to try and these jackals these absolute
hyenas rip them all apart before I can
even have the opportunity to get mine
it's my only complaint about the whole
thing make sure you go right now for a
limited time this summer to balance of
nature when you become a preferred
customer they are throwing in a free
fruit and veggies travel set and giving
an additional 25 bucks off your first
order go to balanceofnature.com promo
code Knowles Canada wies for a free
travel set and 25 bucks off your first
order is a preferred customer that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
uh Jared Roberts of binal Law Group who
is a zealous litigator I hope extremely
zealous so that he can win this case
Jared thank you for coming on the show
hey thanks for having me Michael uh just
to clarify uh not not litigating uh not
an attorney of in this case specifically
I'm representing the president in other
cases currently but do have some insight
uh for this one this case just
cropped up about 12 hours ago so I'm
sure the dust is still settling on this
uh what's going on in this case and
what's and and broadly what's going on
with the Trump's defense against the
seven billion indictments that are
coming down before 2024.
say you were just talking about why
they're bringing these indictments how I
view it is the president president Trump
is looking great in polling in recent
polls and that the left is honestly
terrified that they're going to lose to
him again and that they're going to lose
power because they know what's going to
happen when President Trump gets back
into office that they're all going to
lose their jobs and so now they're in
full panic mode and you look at the
charges that were brought against
President Trump yesterday and
they're really just Preposterous charges
I mean a lot of them involved the First
Amendment first of all covers the
majority of what president Trump did on
January 6th the president had a right to
petition the government that's within
the first amendment so to charge the
president with a civil rights charge for
using his first amendment I mean that
opens up the statue into a point where a
court could even find that down the road
to be unconstitutionally vague the same
can be said with the charge regarding
interference with an official proceeding
all he did was engage in the in election
contest as a candidate and as a
president and saying that that's a crime
I mean this is a statute that the doj
loves to use all the time and now this
could really hamper the doj's efforts
elsewhere if this statute becomes so
broad that a court rules the
unconstitutional so I mean what we're
seeing here is Jack Smith is desperate
and he's really trying to stretch the
law to create something when there's
nothing in there so of all the legal
threats I agree in my untutored view
looking at this indictment this one
seems particularly weak at least legally
though politically it seems a bit
stronger because unlike the documents
case which is being tried in Florida a
generally friendlier state with a
friendlier judge this is being tried in
DC a less friendly district with a much
less friendly judge so politically I
guess it could be kind of risky even if
the charges are flimsy of all the
charges that Trump is looking at past
present and future what do you think if
any pose a significant threat to the
campaign or to the man's freedom
I've reviewed all the charges analyze
them and I mean there's nothing there
for any of them obviously the most risky
one is going to DC uh Tanya Truckin is
not the greatest drawing that the
president could have gotten as a judge
she's a former colleague of Hunter Biden
actually
and not a good sign no so it's not I
mean although these are the weakest
charges that are brought they're all
weak but these charges especially are
Preposterous this is a very unfavorable
jurisdiction and there's a reason that
Jack Smith is pulling president Trump
out of his home District into DC because
he's looking for an easy win and he's
really willing to stretch the rule of
law no matter the cost do you looking
down the pike now before 2024 you you've
got the documents case scheduled for May
20th I think it is you've got this new
case coming up uh how many of these are
actually going to go to trial before the
election
I can't tell you the answer to that
um we're currently involved in uh
majority civil litigation however I can
tell you that I
judge Trucking especially is going to
want to move this case along very
quickly however there's going to be a
lot of motions practice and things are
going to be drawn out I mean president
Trump has great lawyers that will be
representing him in DC and one motion
that I think will be interesting that
could be brought is under uh the
impeachment judgment Clause president
Trump was already acquitted for these
charges and what I think that emotion
under this uh would definitely be
beneficial whether or not judge chucking
honors it or not that's a different
story but it's important to remember
that President Trump has already been
acquitted so that's a that's a really
interesting point so you're saying just
as for any ordinary citizen you can't be
tried twice for the same thing if you
tried and you're acquitted they can't
just bring you to trial again for the
exact same charges what you're saying is
we already had a trial here it was
called the impeachment trial and Trump
was acquitted he wasn't convicted and so
okay bye you know this this is over
in theory I think that can be the case
yeah I mean the Constitution lays out
the if Congress views the president
exceeded
his duties and went outside of that the
only remedy against the president is the
is impeachment they went through that
process president Trump was acquitted
and now to bring him again on these new
charges is absurd all right uh that's
it's a little glimmer of hope there uh
Jared I have to let you go there thank
you so much for making the time to hop
on we will uh probably have to have you
back as as these uh indictments just
keep rolling in that seems by the week
thank you very much for coming on I
appreciate it Michael thank you boy what
a great clip that was huh make sure you
subscribe ring the bell to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel see you next
time